so how do you find what you are meant to
create and that's extremely hard and I
talked to a lot of folks who feel lost
in understanding what that might be
there's there's two things that I found
for me that we're really helpful the
first is to say yes to all the things
that you would normally say no to and
the more uncomfortable it makes you feel
the more you should do it so when I was
struggling with this almost I guess it
was almost 15 years ago like okay I'm
just going to just do anything
ridiculous I could possibly do and so I
as you can imagine I'm an internet geek
so I don't go outside all that much so
like okay I'm gonna go to Alaska and I'm
going to go camping and I'm going to do
it with a bunch of strangers I could not
think of anything sort of more
terrifying than being around a bunch of
people that I don't know in the middle
of the freezing cold with nothing around
so I did that and it was amazing it was
so awesome it was so great I went
dumpster diving was with a bunch of
anarchists that was really awesome I
mean if you know I might've gotten sick
but it was totally fine um I
I'm odd 'old for like an entire week and
that was horrifyingly awful I learned
very quickly that I hated that um but so
that's that's one way the other way is
not obvious at all I found that in
sharing your story with somebody else
someone who doesn't necessarily have to
know you very well or sometimes they or
they can just it doesn't really matter
but if you reflect back with someone
else the story of your life it can go on
for hours and hours and hours they can
start to tell you the themes that emerge
that you would never sort of see
yourself one of things that's
challenging when you're extremely
talented at something is that it's
really easy for you and so you generally
generally don't value it as much as that
think that's really hard and so
somebody else can see that in you
frequently much better than you can and
what I found is just share your story
with each other reflecting back oh like
you know in my life community and
connection and the Internet and how all
that connects together was a really big
part of my life and that helps me
understand who I was and what I was
uniquely meant to create here so finding
one other person to share that with a
good listener is another great way to
find it